hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so yesterday i gave you
a full video guys only on amc so i want
to do the same today for gme of course
because those two stocks to me they are
legendary stocks that are going to be
remembered for a long time and they are
the two leaders of the meme movement
so let's have a look today at gme
[Music]
alright guys so bam gme
what do we have a bit the same kind of
pattern as we do on amc surprisingly
right of course not it's the same flows
that go in both stocks because those
stocks they are not traded based on
fundamentals
that shared it based on emotions based
on the flows money for follow the money
you know how it works right so
that makes total sense for me that those
two stocks have the same kind of
patterns even if we have some big
differences first here in jme i think we
are already in the fifth wave because
you can see that we had here this huge
run up i mean this day was crazy when we
went through the 200 to the level that
was of course the level to break out
above and to close above which we
unfortunately didn't manage to do but
when you see this strong kind of moves
you know that you know we have some
impulsive moves and it's not corrective
anymore so i'm not hundred percent sure
of this counting yet but for now
discount team is following me for the
past two months
uh it's pretty accurate it's giving me
good levels um
i was personally a buyer at 170
so it's always a risk when you buy the
dip but here it worked pretty well i
personally took here a little bit of
protection that i already got out
from you know because
usually the first time you arrive on the
breakout you're not breaking it the
first time you you usually need to go
twice maybe three times to eat you need
to have those consolidation just below
like we had here so what's the situation
right now we failed we tried once we
failed all right but bears remember
bears are scared all right and both take
confidence don't you feel better when
you see jamie doing those strong moves
you do so how do you think bears feel
they feel bad all right so this is what
we want them to feel bad and right now
what is happening we're just taking back
some energy consolidating so what is my
view here first we are above the moving
averages 20 and 50 which is uh good
which is bullish which means that the
probability we go higher tomorrow is
higher than the probability we go lower
that's it so first information then in
terms of counting this might be a first
wave so you guys know that second waves
they like to go to the 61.8 percent
retracement which is surprisingly where
we are at 198 so i'm not the only one
using this method and to be a buyer here
and like i said i bought some puts here
in this uh move up because i kind of
felt it won't happen right away and i
sold my puts in this area as well
because i think that right now we are
ready to move higher but if we don't
it's fine all right it's totally fine
because we have more supports below and
once again just like for amc i'm kind of
neutral slightly more bullish on gme the
chart looks better let's be honest uh on
the short term uh what i want to see is
as usual guys the price action coming
close to this breakout trend line
and
ideally to close above so one full day
above so right now the level is at 225
and then we still have this 200 to the
level that is a very important level and
if i have a close above 230 i can tell
that i will be buying more calls even if
if i already have some it would be the
right time to do it but we need a close
and why here was buying food and then
cheryl's buying i would be buying calls
it's just because the first time usually
is not the right one especially when you
arrive that extended we had here another
sold rsi when we arrived look at the rsi
right now back to 40 15 it's the levels
darisa needs to be when we uh you know
this is
this is what we call the the build up
you have some long position build up
uh that is characterized by this
consolidation not far from the breakout
area with rsi coming lower a decreasing
volume on a decreasing price action this
is good news as well we don't want to
see the volume going higher when the
price goes lower all right because you
know what it means it means that the
more that more and more bears are
catching the move down and that they you
know they
they grow strengths and they grow
confident so we don't want this to
happen and we don't have it we have less
traders uh in the move down so people
are waiting all right just like me and i
would be a buyer here
i would be a buyer lower as well
so what else can i say on gme we might
enter the third wave here so the third
off the third right
okay the fifth that goes to 800 and
inside this fifth wave
as usual guys five waves one one two
three four five inside two abc three
four and five all right so i think that
this is what is happening so once again
can we go lower yes is there a problem
no are we gonna have support around 190
level yes because we have the moving
averages and then we have the 200-day
moving average lower at 180. i would
personally not increase my position
above this level uh and once again i
would increase it on the upside as well
once the breakout is confirmed depending
the level we're having of course if we
close right away at 350 i'm not gonna
buy there let's be honest but if we
close at 240 i would be a buyer what
else can i can i say let's have a look
guys at the synthetic short and the dtc
is very important and the 950 strike
that is here huge
bam
i'm checking the dtc guys
five
4.99
very close to five guys those are levels
of squeeze right amc at three point five
jimmy at five
and look at the strike the
the 950 strike is right now at four
million shares guys this is growing this
is bullish uh total shot is 17 if i take
into account the regular shot 12 and the
synthetic show that is 5
right now but that can go up to 28
this is what we call gamma and let's
check what are the big strikes 300 oh
right i'd like to see that all right you
can see amc is 40 we are 40.
jamie is more bullish just in terms of
the option market once again i repeat
amc has its biggest strike on the 4d
level let me show you that guys this
here again i know it's a gm video but
come on i can show you quickly the
difference with amc
okay
so you can see the biggest strike so of
course it's at 145 but before that it's
at 40 just on the money so it means the
momentum is happening right now not
higher then we have something higher as
well but look on jimmy where is the
biggest strike which is that's why the
reason why i'm more bullish just looking
at option markets on gme okay
refreshing refreshing refreshing bam bam
bam
okay and 4.99 of course nothing new and
here you can see the biggest one so of
course here
oh
gm is really bullish the option market
800 is huge and 950 is absolutely
massive four million shares guys
when i see that i feel like my target is
too low you know my target was 800 but
when i see that the target should be
1100 1200 because if we go close to 950
we're gonna cross it that's the way it
works when you have those big gamma
positions
what else quickly where is it coming
from just like amc massively coming from
the gen 22 maturity i'm there as well i
think it's the right maturity to trade
and i'm going to check if we have this
role positions from the gen to the march
22 or to the gen 23 maturity when the
maturity arrives if we do have this uh
roles that we see which means investors
put more money buy more premium on the
longer term maturity and cut the
position on gen 22 for example this is
bullish this means it would last longer
this is the reason why it's been one
year i'm talking about amc and jimmy and
i'm gonna keep talking about it whenever
i see this guys because this is just
insane i'm checking so many different
stocks and i can tell you that
none of them has this kind of option uh
market distribution and this is
extremely bullish this is the sign for
me that something huge is happening i
mean will happen is happening whatever
we are in it it's coming soon guys i can
check the end of the triangle here kind
of the same you see gen 22 so something
is going to happen before gen 22 and you
know my view guys i think it's going to
be on the upside and it's going to be
absolutely massive so what can we expect
guys if we have this breakout if we
close at 240 i can tell you that
the 300 strike is huge right look bam
300 strike huge so we're gonna go
through the 300 strike
probably and
find
probably resistance at 340. i would
personally be taking some profits here
but buying puts again i would buy be
buying puts around 340 and would sell
those puts around 250 just quickly you
know i keep my calls so if you go higher
i'm happy but if we correct i'm not
happy but i managed to lock in some
profits and then i'm gonna sell my puts
if we go back to 250 and this is you
know swing trading i'm gonna
buy puts here sell puts here and just
let it run to the 800 or maybe even
higher levels
so that's it for today guys i hope you
enjoyed this video i will keep of course
updating you guys nonstop on amcgme i'm
talking about more stocks as well
because i know that some of you want to
see something else as well but jimmy and
amc are the two big boys that i'm never
gonna stop talking about until we have
this squeeze so stay close to shore